what's going on reject nation we're back
at it again we are going to watch the
boys season two
episode five very excited to check this
one out today make sure to subscribe and
click that notification bell
so you can get notified whenever we have
a new reaction for the boys up
side note youtube only allows for about
10 minutes worth of footage of the show
to be included
if we're lucky enough for that and if
there's music in the episode
you usually have to keep that
exceptionally low to at least get this
visible on youtube with that in mind
this is going to be reaction highlights
full length reaction watch alongs where
you sync up with the time code will be
available
over at our patreon page thank you to
everyone who's joined our patreon so
far especially for those who wanted to
watch along with us for the boys
specifically over there we cover a lot
of shows where we have at the same tier
reaction highlights and watch-alongs
included for
look at all these shows oh my god i got
pictures of so many of them
supernatural doctor who just to name a
couple out of a gazillion that are there
i feel like i've talked plenty enough
now to the point where i have featured
at least one thumbnail graphic
out of all of these shows last but not
least i want to thank
eric over at nerdchronic for editing
these reaction highlights for us
yes from movie trivia showdown a whole
bunch of reactors thank you so much eric
for being you
you rock my socks i'm pretty sure this
is the smoothest i've ever done
this entire intro ever let's do this
[Music]
is this the movie definitely
if you hadn't broken into that dhs
mainframe
true i am hell of a hack it's the same
color grading of the zack snyder built
so who are you maeve a lesbian
oh my god i'm gay
i'm gay hey marty play that back please
yeah joss rewrite really
i'm inspired you inspired oh yeah girls
get it on
done girls get it done you're due right
now
she corrected
dude this is pbs
[Music]
oh
oh there's real life that's real oh [ __ ]
this is part of the movie
so what they're all starving but one of
them's got a [ __ ] cell phone
oh my god
jason momoa what are you doing
you picked the biggest strongest guy and
you fight him
owie
no he wants the pain yeah before a cobot
i did this every single time before a
living i fought
before to prep myself for the fight
apparently that's that joke
i'm not i'm not mad you know oh
you might i i just want you to know that
um
kid has said goodbye oh oh you were
always on my canary i suppose
thank you goodbye huey
called me his canary
we need to find him i'm [ __ ] real
that's the code word
hey what's his name john widow's name
greg
grundberg but how are you gonna get
through all of them don't worry
[Laughter]
your father's quite ill cancer spreading
fast
you were not fast enough i ain't seeing
them no where's me boy
his dog this cat dog i called it
oh buddy
tara you little rascal oh
i hope nothing happens to the dog i'm a
little worried now
no it's only marine animals guys it's
when we see life
yeah you know kevin here has had some
issues in the past but he has not
sexually assaulted me the entire time
we've been together
well she's only saying that because i
make her breakfast in bed so oh french
toast
oh cringey
[Music]
so gross slowly just ripped his face off
don't run over your dog man is that
black noir
it totally is real subtle yeah
you know you have a really defined black
costume
broad daylight on rooftop right ma'am do
you have any nails ball bearings
electrical wiring pressurized aerosol
products i need a can about this big
i really appreciate it i don't know
anything what he's talking about
i have one pan in the under the cupboard
like mom
this isn't a great time i i know that
she's
really racist mom
she likes to kill people everyone is
upset about compound v i mean
someone was so upset they leaked it to
the press can you imagine how angry that
person is
whoever they are oh [ __ ]
if it was me whoever they are i'd be
grateful to have a mom like donna
yeah cause she's white don't make me
move you
you can move him
good luck with me
dude i love eminem so much mm
is like the leader of the show now i now
know the kind of man i want to be
kind of man who calls out injustice when
he sees it
hey dude that's not cool
[Laughter]
and they immediately stopped the church
used to mean something
what are you a member i was long time
ago
it's a racist church this used to be
pure
and then they just started letting all
kinds of people in
some people are quality and others are
garbage oh by the way
i heard they're retiring you
so unfair you have a problem
of course not why would you say that
she's great in that delivery one
you leave the seven with your dignity
and your severance package intact
or two you get fired for breaching your
morality clause by shooting up compound
v
and giving yourself a [ __ ] heart
attack in the [ __ ] process
it's your choice wow
ashley i used to like you i was
sympathetic towards you
now i think you get what you deserve i
think it's time that i stay put for a
while
is that a standard maybe
probably i think it is it's been a good
run
hey dude that was awesome
no sometimes well these things just
happen
wait this happened before how many times
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you would know that freedom
comes at a price you don't speak for us
don't know better oh man
[Music]
[Applause]
this has to be fantasy this has to be a
has to be a fantasy
they make for good dramatized stakes
what a bummer
he's losing his [ __ ]
[Music]
you should have boned yourself in the
last episode man yeah
the kid's a hero think of it like that
right sage groves
huh sean ashmore i was gonna say are you
explaining a racist
who's lenny you said i look like him
skinny nervous little bugger
like you hmm hey actually
it is you the wanker need dory and
savory
breaks lenny's nose oh billy goes to
work on him
he's bringing the sea sword down on
dorian's noggin where
where lenny steps in faithful
bleeding and leads billy away easy quiet
as a lamb
why is he so disturbed by this story
where's lenny now
oh god dust is so
he really has it out for butcher i think
you've got a bollocks
oh come on then [ __ ]
yeah i said all his words
[Music]
holy [ __ ] he's like not hurt at
all oh
then the dog's gonna come in shooting at
him
[Laughter]
double no wheeling
no i'm not looking i'm not looking
you kill him you can kiss your [ __ ]
career goodbye
one [ __ ] finger on any of us
and those photos go out of the cloud and
answer ronin
locks boogie
i reckon you might want to keep it that
way
how can i be sure you actually have the
proof which you speak
cool that information never sees the
light of day
and i'll call off black noir boy
this is once a word
please leave you all right peace
okay
[Laughter]
they said there'd be food well this is
food for your soul
it looks exactly like a diet book
me my god hi wait are you
do you want to check this out oh [ __ ] no
okay oh
then you're gonna need a woman to tell
everyone that you're
not a complete piece of [ __ ] that's why
i got married
i could be that person for you if you
take on homelessness
[ __ ] you the point is
what are you doing in my trailer you
know you had no right to talk to my
mother
about personal [ __ ] good that's good
don't try and broker some kind of peace
between us because
i don't want it dude
starlight great lie more cover-up for
this
that is a performance
oh never mind mug you
leaked it to msnbc now what do you think
vox's gonna feel
when i tell her how does she know all
this well how do you
think the world will feel when i tell
them that
you used to be liberated oh games are on
game of chess here we go
you're gonna be a big help to me what
the hell does that mean
is it home come in yes definitely
homeland not interrupting emma
no no just between us girls right
starlight
yeah that's right
see you around hello now she's got
homelander back her up
i know i owe you
well what are you ever gonna do to repay
me kill a bunch of black people
oh my god that is the scariest question
so far
that's something she would want i got
you something
tara and you [ __ ]
you blew up my house my my little nephew
now they're going to find me selling
drugs down
guys dream on by arrows at this playing
but it's not playing in the video so the
video
can still be visible on youtube
but no can we hear it just a heads up
everyone hold the phone oh my god it's
happening
i knew i thought i would be wrong oh my
oh man everyone
oh god oh bdsm
don't be a [ __ ] laser my [ __ ] tit oh
my god
don't stop
i told you i don't break easy
he looks like a he's the perfect nazi
looking guy too
here you go that's probably why she
loves him so much
oh now they're being sweet oh no
he's gonna like care about her
wow so wow
odd superhero sucks
good for them
just spam fun for
we can't show that part of this youtube
card out watchman
yeah this is my favorite episode of
season two so far
this is like the brilliance of the boys
every frame all its commentary
throughout we meshed it with having a
high stakes plot
raising the stakes on every single
situation at hand and it was my favorite
that they've done with the boys
themselves because
i feel like you know the everything with
the soups has been way more interesting
than
anything to go on with the boys but then
other than like butcher situation
with him and becca but having uh this
storyline with them pulling
butcher out of his slump or trying to
help him out i thought was really
wonderful
olivia what did you think i thought it
was the best episode so far
of this season especially after i was eh
meh
last episode i felt like it was starting
to kind of get dull and wasn't really
intriguing this kept my attention
uh i was on the edge of my seat
sometimes i didn't expect a lot of
things to happen so yeah it was really
good it had
good character bits between both soup
and the boys characters and it had
a lot of the satire that i love
especially on like the movie sets and
the pr
breaking the fourth wall and then you
know going with the homelander being
seen as a terrorist yeah this just gave
me all of those different thrills that i
come to hope for in a boys episode the
main big takeaway moments
obviously for for me i'm i'm really
flashing mortals like yeah
dog so glad tara got to live man gotta
live
it's that's a rarity nowadays everything
with homelander
and then of course like how stormfront
is slowly
slowly like it's so insidious
how she's like making her way to
controlling the seven
yeah i'm not even controlling but making
sure that
now homeland is gonna look out for her
instead of them being enemies
she's now made it to where he's going to
consider her
a teammate really yeah not a teammate
like he'd use everyone else but an
actual this person has helped me now i
have a sexual relationship
i think she's incredibly brilliant
terrifying absolutely
terrifying i i i'm wondering do you guys
think
that she had something to do with the
footage where homelander killed
that guy that's caused all these
protests to start happening do you think
that she had some type of involvement
with that being captured and being
released to the public or
does she just know how to play her cards
right with opportunity that's been
presented on her lap i think she just
knows how to play her card right now
that makes her even crazier even more
killer man i'm also hesitant to say that
that because you've been writing about a
few things so far
i'm surprised about some things i've
been right about to be honest
there's something sorry i would have
these predictions and then the show
would start going in this direction i'm
like
all right that thing's not gonna happen
then it suddenly starts crossing into
territory i'm like oh damn
that thing's happening everyone here
that they focused on i thought had great
scenes everything with
what's his name is anthony starred the
actor's name anthony stark anthony starr
who plays homelander
this guy would like this false bravado
in a way like he's just this insecure
man-child who's in the body of superman
and he's got this like real violent rage
and just
wants approval all around lashes out at
everyone his performance is so damn
nuanced in every single
moment he's on screen the choices that
they make with this character just make
sense all the time like to have these
protests
of course homelanders gonna show up and
try to fix this themselves
he thinks that he has this natural
ability to persuade in his ego
that inflated to the point where he can
actually go to the protest i think he
can make a difference by speaking up
over there yeah what will this do to him
though i feel like this will be the
final crack in his facade and his mental
state
once it's revealed that she's a big old
racist and she
likes to kill people of color and now
he's [ __ ] her and
now he's all team her and he wasn't able
to see it and she
used him i think that's gonna be the
final like psychotic break for him
well what makes me curious too with
stormfront is
mr edgar is a person of color he
personally hired her
does she have any issues with having to
work
did he hire her because she it was
revealed that she's been
in vaught for years i thought that she
was personally selected when she was
first introduced that's what she said
but then it was revealed that she was
liberty liberty was
in bots okay and so she's been part of
vap
probably for longer than he has oh yeah
what there's
there's so much to unpack with how she's
still like for her to have formerly been
liberty and then still be within vaude
and then now to be coming at a
storefront there's so much to unpack
with what the real deal is with her
because she's not afraid to show her her
real colors on the inside from you know
time to time that conversation with a
train i really do think we're getting to
a point where a train is gonna be
helping out starlight and huey
some way we're gonna get to that point
and everything they do with this show so
far
i i love the angle that they're going
with him because last season
i like the a train character i like
watching him on screen i didn't
like like him as a person and this time
around i'm really starting to feel sorry
for the guy
the show has managed to make me feel
sympathy for him in a way where i'm like
oh man
you poor dude everyone just keeps
pushing you to the side i really liked
his scene work that he had here even
with that uh the
director character i thought did a
really good job interweaving throughout
all these scenes they flat out say
the jossery right on it i know so was
joss whedon
was that just some jab homelander was
making or
are they no one was a homelander uh
homelanders said that yeah
so or or is it an actual that are they
saying like joss whedon is a
did a rewrite on this script i feel like
they're actually implying that he didn't
really
know this because there's just yeah like
their their uh satire of the movies
especially is so involved
so much further down i find it funny uh
that they're you know going at dc and
superheroes in general but dc
so much because you know this reminds me
of what zack snyder was talking about
with his like bvs and justice league
movies about how your
your heroes aren't these like shiny you
know perfect beings but this
is like quadrupling down yeah by
comparison and so i do think it's
interesting that yeah
they draw so much from that and that
just yeah seemed like the exact joke to
throw in because of course it's right up
to the minute with pop culture too
it really does amaze me how like as each
episode
progresses with whatever commentary
wants to do how it feels more relevant
to
everything that's gone on in the last
few months when they shot this show last
year yeah and they have all this stuff
with me i was gonna say and all this
inclusivity
all this false inclusivity and seeing
that from behind the scenes like that
was one of those things where i was like
oh my goodness i wonder if this is based
on real people's experiences
oh it has to be man yeah like that's one
of those things yeah that is razor sharp
and makes you look around at a lot
of the other things that are popping up
in the movie sphere right now or for the
past couple years and you can hear those
conversations in the back of your mind
informing them
i really like the the approach they've
been doing
with especially in the commentary
department with elena and maeve i do
feel
it would be stronger if the elena and
maeve dynamics
and their relationship yeah if that was
more rich they are not
written in this show the way of what
they're making fun of
which is good but at the same time i do
feel it would be stronger
if uh you know if their actual
relationship was something to
get more invested in you know because i
mean this has been a thing that
you know a lot of people have spoken
about over the years is that like you
know the representation not only just of
gay people but especially like lesbians
and bisexual people is really
skewed and off the mark for the most
part in a lot of popular media and so i
liked
seeing them here try to attack that with
some satire but i feel like
some of that gets kneecapped yeah with
the fact that we don't know maeve and
elena super duper well compared to a lot
of the other characters so yeah having
some kind of more intimate or tender
moments or things that aren't just
related directly to the main plot with
them of some kind might be nice just to
yeah really legitimize those characters
but i love that what how they make fun
of you got the men calling the shots and
then you got this false sense of female
empowerment they're making fun of the
hashtags on the hero shot of the three
women together you know
yeah what do you think about her and
attempt to get the deep in to take down
homelander i don't really know what that
even means i don't know
what they would do together what the
hell are they gonna do at home i don't
know especially now that stormfront's
there and she
doesn't appear to be he can't really
hurt her yeah
a train seems like the most formidable
member of our like non-homelander seven
right now who could be
like on the side of maybe not the seven
eventually maeve
i i like a lot of aspects of her
character but i would like to see more
of an arc
happen because i'm constantly sitting
here being like come on
step up to some of the things that made
you part of the seven
like do something to show that you are a
hero in some way
i just feel that stormfront's going to
say something about
maeve's attempt here elena's going to
get killed off
is going to get killed off how does
stormfront know everything about
starlight
how does she know all that that's a good
question
i mean she wasn't very subtle when she's
talking to gekko man though
also true i mean it would be easier to
go like hey this guy looks at the lab
he brought her something yeah and all of
a sudden the comment
let me go back and look at the cameras
but what's like what's like the long
game
the end game that she has with starlight
especially if she knows all this
information you know also this is the
best starlight i've seen
of this whole season too i
like horribly i mean yeah she's not
intimidating but i thought the work that
she did in this episode what they did
with her character
was the most naturally engaging i
thought like her mom showing back
up yeah that was good i was uh i was
very invested in that and i love
obviously being in the audience seat
when she's sneaking on to that's
you know we did a dope trope live stream
last week and that is a trope i don't
like when the characters figure out the
password yeah
like come on like how do they figure it
out one conversation that they had
earlier i
it's it's like every tv show movie they
just like try like three times
yeah it's always something in the room
or something i recently mentioned
but when starlight was using her mom as
an excuse to be
in the room with stormfront i was here
going man that's great that's a great
story i totally buy this is awesome yeah
that's the star front to season right
through it though and
i think that's good storytelling or at
least good filmmaking when you could be
the audience see thinking that
stormfront could believe something like
this and then
immediately have the flip around to go
oh no stormfront's not falling for this
as much as i've really been liking
everything with the boys
this thing with frenchie though i find
to be
very underwritten like frenchy
everything with kimiko
i enjoy a lot frenchie is just like
chemical upset that's just yeah
last season he's french guy and then
this season he's just chemical obsessed
guy
and i thought he had a lot more nuance
and there's a lot more richness with his
character in the first season
and then this particular one as much as
i like how he serves as the uh
sensitive pull for kimiko who is this
violent creature
um what'd you think of kimiko's moment
though when she was in the church like
sign language yelling the whole time
i've really fell for that personally
i hate that [ __ ] quite honestly really
it's
cliche like i i don't know i feel like
it's over the top
especially that scene i felt like it was
just too much in that moment
whatever that's just my opinion that's
fair i
like her performance a lot i think she's
a great performer i think that
it can come off as over the top when
she's
just sitting there screaming at him and
she knows he does not understand her
that's what but
she [ __ ] knows he does not understand
her it's just over the top scene
especially like in the environment with
the church
and then him on the floor crying like us
whatever
and nobody noticed i mean like that i
know that trope of like let's meet in a
big beautiful church
do some clandestine thing it's ironic
why do they all know and then there are
a couple people here that aren't gonna
do anything while we cause a scene
i think the way their plot points
envelop feel
the most generic out of everyone else's
plot points
i still think the performance of her
though i agree that getting to that
point
felt like yeah it's kind of a generic
moment what makes it unique is
she's doing it in sign language you know
i really like the emotions of that see i
like both of them as performers a whole
lot and so that's one thing that i
really wish
would kind of grow for this season
especially because like there
have been moments again with frenchie
that have brought on nuanced
conversations but not necessarily so
much that we
learn more about his character or endear
more and uh yeah
and then even in this episode like the
boys was literally minus fringes yeah
so why was it why weren't they included
in on that like they just
we didn't get any explanation as to why
they were to stop doing their own thing
i feel like that this thing with kimiko
and like kimiko gets like the best
violent moments
but i think like this thing with kimiko
and uh frenchie is feeling like an
isolated part of the rest of the story
especially now that they're separated
and it seemed like it was gonna be such
a a main part of the story
yeah everything homelander and the seven
and butcher whatever they're doing and
that feels equal
and then below that is chemical and
frenchie the way bottom of that is like
the deep
you know yeah yeah comic strip you know
absolutely i want to see
that marriage i wanted a reality
slice in the life of the deep and yeah
it's pretty crazy how much they
deal with like media manipulation in
this series and i
really love that like of course you got
political commentary throughout
but media manipulation is some of my
favorite that i think this show has such
a great handle on
what they did with butcher and i feel
like mother's milk is becoming like the
leader of the boys
for sure he's the blue he's the glue
yeah and
that whole sequence i thought at the
home there could be a line that you
cross here with butcher where you get
too
sensitive with the guy or too vulnerable
like wolverine and x-men the last stand
where you get like
too soft and they managed to not
cross that line because they still keep
his dialogue get away from me kind of
manner where he's
saying all the lines that butcher would
say yeah he's still apprehensive to
every
to a form of connection even when he is
feeling downtrodden and despondent and
whatever
huey and mother's milk showing up and
then that dynamic reveal that we
understand
deeper with how huey could represent uh
butcher's brother on a little bit of a
subconscious level
makes more sense to their to why butcher
can
uh lean towards uh huey a little bit
yeah but what they did
with huey and butcher's relationship in
this episode
i really loved how you got endeared a
little bit more to a softer side to them
especially after
butchery gets pushed to the point where
he's uh threatening
black noir and then you just see this
little smile exchange that forms between
huey and butcher afterwards when he asks
him do you really do you really have
that footage or do you really have
uh whatever yeah the pit do you really
have the pictures even though they
disagree on a lot there's this level of
care and respect
that definitely is there and it really
showed a lot in this episode and i
really
appreciated those moments and i liked
butcher's aunt
i did i liked her too yeah i feel like
characters that could get annoying but i
liked her here i feel like that was the
best part those
those scenes with them were the best
parts of the episode it was the most
heartfelt for sure yeah
and it also i mean to me the thing with
butcher's brother also sells
some of the conflict between him and
huey because
you know i mean obviously he loves him
he cared about him but you know brothers
have conflict all the time yeah so at
least to me watching i was like oh okay
like
especially having that reminder there of
you know if he does kind of resemble his
brother i would imagine it brings back
some of those memories for butchers
yeah so yeah like it injected a good
amount more character here i felt like
for them especially
all right guys well that's it for
today's episode make sure to subscribe
and click that notification bell thank
you to everyone who follows on patreon
so
far let us know your thoughts down below
of what you thought of this episode
last but not least
hey we're back in here andrew hayes i
just wanted to shout you out today buddy
you told me recently
that you and your friends are working on
an
unfriended movie i don't know what this
means exactly but i wish you and your
friends the best of luck the reason i
wanted to shout you out today i was
looking through our list
and i said to myself who looks the most
like homelander
at our patreon page you lucked out today
man
you look the most like homelander
you're a very lucky guy you should find
your doppelganger and just go to town
because there's nothing higher standard
than that
you gotta find your storm front matter
of fact i don't even think you'll watch
this show
i think you're gonna wait till the end
of the month see where we shadowed you
out
hop to the end of the video get this
shout out you're gonna be like
i don't get these references but if greg
and john are saying this this must be
good things all around i wish you would
watch me like black noir
don't break up with me in a church
references i love you i love you too